Kathy Sheena is the mayor of Albany New
York the capital of that state it's also
a sanctuary city and she joins us
tonight Miss Marron I see good to see
you
so I just I can't resist asking about
the Disneyland video that we just showed
people here illegally blocking entry to
Americans in the amusement park because
they're demanding citizenship and free
stuff what what country would put up
with that other than ours well listen
this is a country that values free
speech and the right to protest and
these are young people who feel that
they were given a promise and that daca
was a way for them these are young
people who were brought over here as
children not by their choice as a way
for them to have a pathway to
citizenship and this is a great country
and that we allow people the freedom to
foreigners by the way why would you want
someone in your country who's not
grateful to be here who's demanding of
American citizens the right to vote and
get benefits don't you want people who
are grateful to be here I want to add
you know every immigrant that I've ever
met is grateful to be here that doesn't
mean that they're not going to stand up
for their rights and you know I joined
thousands of people across this country
in protests that happened on Saturday
from people who were born and raised in
this country and who've been here for
generations that is one of the hallmarks
of our Great Society are not Americans
these but they have a voice they have a
right to a voice just because you're not
from here doesn't mean the Constitution
doesn't apply to you if you're here well
well well if you're if you're if you
broke our law to get here you don't have
the rights of American citizen have
where do those rights come from this so
you know when when you are here you have
constitutionally protected rights and I
think that when we look to polarize this
conversation by pointing these people
who are here brought here by their
parents without their without their
choice and demonizing them we really
trigger conversations versus them whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa they block the
entrance to Disneyland okay I didn't do
that
they did that do they bury any
responsibility for it and there are
Americans who use their right to free
speech to block entrances to shut down
roads and to protest things in this
country you see whether you will do
we're here are you weren't born matter
but you will have that right no it's a
matter of citizenship citizenship is
meaningful to most Americans they think
if you're different if you're a citizen
they want to be on a path to citizenship
these are young people who are working
hard and we have work these are people
who in the model be on a path day we're
blocking a Disneyland so does how many
they were working hard so a new poll by
hi new Harvard poll shows that four out
of five Americans eighty-one percent of
Americans want less legal immigration a
lot less where were their interests
where are their interests in the modern
Democratic Party four out of five
Americans of all political parties one
less legal immigration are you aware of
that well and I think that that's really
a stunning number and it demonstrates
that we need to do a better job of
communicating how important immigration
is to our cities into our country and
you know you look at a city like Albany
New York we have an aging population a
lot of the growth that's happening in
our city is happening because of
immigration the number one complaint I
get from employers is that they can't
find people to work and so we've got a
real workforce development challenge in
the city of Albany and in the Capital
Region and immigration is helping to
fuel that workforce
I wonder though I mean so for example I
was just looking at stats provided by
the Albany School District and I think
you've said before that your city is
about 40 percent foreign-born no no it's
about 11 percent but we have about 40
languages 40 lines my mistake that's
pretty high number
so in 2017 of eighth graders in Albany
Schools 0% qualified 0% according to
your stats qualified in math well that
seems to me like a crisis much larger
than anything you're describing that's
where the challenge is in our school
district existed before we had the
immigration that we chose I'm not saying
but I'm just saying like what I wonder
why I've never heard you as outraged
about that as you are about I don't know
enforcing federal immigration law that
seems like a crack would you agree
that's a crisis zero person
that booth graters well that that's
absolutely right and that is why you
know that's an another whole
conversation we can we can have about
the work that we are doing to partner
with our school district and to ensure
that we're turning that around and by
bringing together our institutions of
higher education our business community
you know healthcare so that we and we
are addressing those issues think that
bringing in more students who don't have
English as a first language helps or
hurts that I think that when we when you
look at what we are doing with our new
language learners that we are making
having interventions that are helping
them to so it's a problem you need to
solve you just conceded it's a problem
you're trying to make the problem better
but it is a problem when you import
people who don't speak English as a
first language why would you add that
burden to schools where zero percent of
eighth graders are proficient in math to
zero percent well first of all that
numbers a little misleading because of
how the testing is done that's your
number but if you if you passed the
region exam you didn't have to take the
tests that you're talking about but in
any event the when you look at the
challenges that exist in any school
district in any urban school district
it's incumbent upon the school district
and the the stakeholders in that
community to ensure that we're doing
what we can so that these children are
successful does we are some incredible
successes
it doesn't haven't seen this I'm sure
you're seeing some success my only it's
really simple I'm not arguing against
all immigrants I'm not argue against
your schools I'm just saying there's a
crisis in your schools obviously does
importing more immigrants make it better
and you've conceded no it doesn't it's a
problem well just so I don't I don't see
it better or worse I see it as a an
asset to the city to see that we have
the opportunity to continue to grow to
continue to have economic what is that
right numbers then it's bringing in more
people from third world countries makes
Albany a better city is good for your
schools it's good for your economy
what's the right number how many people
do you think need to come from foreign
countries to Albany for you to get
really ready so you know this is where
the federal government needs to step up
and
decide what immigration policy is going
to be that happens at the federal levels
the mayor though you're making the lease
that they make your city more prosperous
I will I would advocate to ensure that
we have enough people on h-1b visas we
are the we have a one of the largest
semiconductor manufacturing facilities
in the Capital Region GES R&D center is
there I worked for a medical device
manufacturer we used h-1b visas to bring
in we're not actually talking about h-1b
visas was a totally different category
we talk about poor people like the daca
recipients who are not h-1b people there
are people with lower than average
educational attainment and my simple
question was if more of poor people
makes your city richer what's the good
number of poor people to bring look I'm
not talking about statistics and numbers
I'm talking about the people who are
there and I'm talking about ensuring
that we continue to be a welcoming
community for everyone okay well that's
a different that's a different goal but
I thought you were saying it made the
city richer and I just AM skeptical
that's it well I think it's helping us
to definitely helping us to grow and to
fill a workforce need that exists thank
you with Merritt it's nice to see you I
appreciate your doing that